Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Allora, io sono belga, fiammingo,
e quindi vi parlerò in…?
In italiano, sì.
Allora, 20 anni fa sono entrato
in quell’edificio verde, che vedete qui,
e che ospita il Museo
delle Tecnologie Giurassiche,
il Museum of Jurassic Technology,
e sapete tutti che il Giurassico
è un’era preistorica in cui il mondo
era popolato dai dinosauri, no?
Però questo museo non parla di dinosauri,
e non parla neanche di tecnologia.
Parla, o fa vedere, e leggo:
"Una scultura di un Papa
dentro l'occhiello di un ago,
da guardare con un microscopio,
un pipistrello incastrato
in un blocco di piombo,
e quindi invisibile,
le corna di una donna inglese.
E quindi è difficile spiegare
il senso di tutto ciò,
e non voglio neanche provarci.
Sta di fatto che, quando esci
da questo museo,
dal buio di questo museo,
e rientri nella luce riverberante
della città di Los Angeles,
sai e senti che il mondo
deve essere un po' più complicato
rispetto a quello che vedi intorno:
la strada, le macchine, i semafori.
Il museo ti ha messo
in uno stato di meraviglia,
che spesso è anche uno stato di dubbio.
Ho poi saputo che qualcuno ha scritto
un libro proprio su questo museo
e lo chiama un degno erede
dei gabinetti delle meraviglie del ‘500.
Ebbene, anche nel '500
era un po' difficile
spiegare il senso di tutto ciò
che si vedeva nel '500, no?
Tutte le novità,
le notizie che arrivavano
con le scoperte delle Americhe
espandevano di molto
l'immaginario collettivo della gente.
Ha creato una confusione generale
che ha governato l'Europa
per più di 100 anni.
E nascevano appunto
queste stanze delle meraviglie,
le Wunderkammer,
dove si raccoglieva proprio di tutto:
le cose più bizzarre,
vere e anche inventate.
E mentre tante di queste collezioni
alimentavano il gusto barocco
per lo straordinario, lo smisurato,
altre diventavano strumenti per lo studio.
In Italia, e per questo mi piace parlare
di tutto ciò in italiano, veramente,
in Italia, tra Leonardo e Galileo,
il bolognese Ulisse Aldovandri
aveva uno scopo ben preciso,
con la sua collezione.
Voleva sistematizzare
e ricomporre il sapere
tramite una ricostruzione
microcosmica del macrocosmo.
A un certo punto scrive,
con un certo orgoglio:
"Oggi nel mio microcosmo
si possono vedere il numero
di 18.000 cose diverse,
veramente esemplari delle specie
prodotte dal grande Iddio".
Infatti, per tanto tempo
ricondurre tutto a un unico Creatore
era l'unico modo di dare qualche coerenza
a questo caos di meraviglie.
Ma pian piano,
le meraviglie dovevano
lasciare spazio ai dubbi
su come fosse stato descritto il mondo
nella Bibbia e nei testi classici.
Aldovandri vedeva la necessità
di cambiare e di ricomporre il sapere.
Il suo primo lavoro è stato
dividere i suoi 18.000 esemplari
in Naturalia e in Artificialia,
quindi cose fatte dalla natura
e cose fatte dall'uomo.
E questo può sembrare banale, no?
Ma all'epoca era un approccio
radicalmente nuovo alla realtà,
un approccio che poi ha portato
al pensiero moderno
e in cui la divisione tra natura e uomo
è diventata la divisione
tra, da una parte le scienze,
e dall'altra parte l'arte,
la religione, la politica, ecc.
Io sono uno scienziato per il mondo,
sono un climatologo.
E mi è sempre parso utile vedere
i cambiamenti climatici di oggi
nel contesto dei cambiamenti avvenuti
in tutta la storia della Terra,
una storia lunga
quattro miliardi e mezzo di anni.
Ma guardiamo solo
gli ultimi 600 milioni di anni,
da quando la vita è emigrata
dall'Oceano alla terraferma,
Dai reperti fossili sappiamo
che ci sono state
queste grandi estinzioni di massa,
causate da cataclismi naturali, no?
Impatti meteoritici, attività vulcanica
e poi i cambiamenti climatici
che ne erano la conseguenza.
Queste estinzioni di massa,
questi strati di fossili, poi,
dividono la preistoria in ere geologiche:
il Giurassico,
ricordate, il Giurassico
andava da 200 a 150 milioni di anni fa.
I primi ominidi sono entrati in scena
solo 7 milioni di anni fa,
e l'Homo Sapiens è a malapena visibile
su questo quadrante.
Quindi faccio un reset dell'orologio
e riparto da 200.000 anni fa,
quando Sapiens entra in scena.
Ci sono poi le diverse rivoluzioni umane,
quella cognitiva, poi quella agricola
e quella industriale.
Ed eccoci subito arrivati
agli ultimi 200 anni,
quelli moderni,
quelli cosiddetti illuminati,
dove troviamo...
musica, Haydn!
E una tale quantità di altre cose
che devo leggervele.
Siamo un miliardo, tanto per cominciare.
C'è il rumore delle macchine a vapore,
macchine che consentono
di fare macchine ancora più grandi.
Il colonialismo, l'abbruttimento dell'uomo
e i primi saccheggi del pianeta.
Ci sono le rivolte sociali,
bombe e fertilizzanti,
la Grande Guerra e l'esplosione
demografica a livello mondiale.
Siamo due miliardi.
Arrivano gli anni ‘30, con New York
che compete con Londra e Berlino,
il primo dispiegamento
di armi di distruzione di massa,
seguito dalla Dichiarazione Universale
dei Diritti dell'Uomo,
il petrolio,
cioè materiale per la plastica,
carburante per le automobili,
città tentacolari.
Siamo tre miliardi.
C’è domanda e offerta,
produzione e consumo di massa,
i gloriosi anni ‘60,
un esplosione di creatività,
la società dell'usa e getta,
il primo trapianto di cuore,
plastica ancora, plastica dappertutto,
pesticidi, organismi
geneticamente modificati,
il freon, il buco dell'ozono,
i viaggi nello spazio,
il personal computer,
Pacman, Super Mario,
CNN e MTV,
Chernobyl, est, ovest, nord, sud,
La Cina in mezzo,
l'Africa dimenticata,
Internet, i mercati finanziari,
la ricerca della sostenibilità,
miniere aperte,
la biodiversità, foreste bruciate,
le reti globali,
riscaldamento globale,
il terrorismo globale,
venti miliardi di polli,
macelli automatici,
trapianto di testa,
la vita virtuale,
siamo più di 7 miliardi,
ed è la disuguaglianza
tra questa donna e questa qua
che scatena conflitto dopo conflitto,
emergenza dopo emergenza,
disastro dopo disastro,
guerra dopo
[Esplosione].
No, scusate. Forse ho..
(Applausi)
Ho forse esagerato un po’,
però è chiaro che il nostro fare
su questo pianeta
ha ormai una forza pari a quello
dei grandi cataclismi
naturali della preistoria.
Adesso siamo noi la causa
del cambiamento climatico.
E anche senza l'uso delle bombe atomiche,
facciamo scomparire
specie animali e vegetali
a un ritmo pari a quello
delle grandi estinzioni di massa.
E per questo ha molto senso
chiamare i nostri tempi "L'Antropocene".
Cioè l'era dell’Antropos, dell'Uomo.
Un'era che potrebbe essere ricordata,
fra un milione di anni,
da uno strato di fossili di varie creature
misti con cemento
e radioattività e plastica.
Beh, sapete, forse non ho esagerato
più di tanto,
perché tutto quello
che ho fatto passare in rassegna
si trova su Internet, su YouTube.
Tanti filosofi, studiosi
della nostra cultura,
hanno chiamato proprio YouTube
una wunderkammer della nostra epoca.
Infatti YouTube fa vedere di tutto,
rispecchia il caos e la confusione
in cui ci troviamo, no?
Un vero “pasticcio” degno del ‘500.
E forse ci troviamo ancora
nello stesso “pasticcio”
e non siamo mai stati moderni,
come dice qualcuno.
Ovviamente ci sono delle differenze
tra il '500 e adesso:
mentre allora le novità venivano
dal nulla, da continenti sconosciuti,
adesso vengono progettate
da un apparato scientifico-tecnologico
per un consumo di massa.
E mentre allora le novità
erano delle vere meraviglie,
adesso le novità non meravigliano più,
perché si soppiantano una dopo l'altra,
e ci siamo abituati oramai
che tutto è possibile.
Mancanza di meraviglia
significa mancanza di dubbio,
e di senso critico
su come operiamo su questo pianeta.
E rimaniamo incastrati
in questo modello consumistico
che è sconnesso da ogni tipo di valore
tranne quello del denaro,
che appiattisce la nostra cultura umana
e che può portare anche alla scomparsa
della nostra civilizzazione,
se non un'altra estinzione di massa.
Guarda[te], io non posso
cambiare il mondo,
ma credo che il mondo
possa essere cambiato,
e per questo ho creato
una stanza delle meraviglie.
Vi ricordate
del Museum of Jurassic Technology?
Ebbene, io ho fondato
the Museum of Antropocene Technology,
un museo che parla dell'Antropocene
e anche un po' di tecnologie.
Per esempio, fa vedere un'opera
che mette in luce
una lampada a incandescenza,
una foto stampata
con l'inquinamento atmosferico stesso
che la foto fa vedere,
un paio di occhiali.
E anche qui, è difficile spiegare
tutto quello che si vede,
ma adesso voglio provarci.
Questi occhiali,
be’, sono occhiali come questi qui,
un oggetto molto semplice, no?
Fatto di plastica e vetro.
Ma qui c'è scritto qualcosa,
che adesso non riesco a vedere,
perché ci vogliono gli occhiali, no?
(Risate)
Ma so che c'è scritto "Made in China",
e questo fa esplodere questo oggetto
in una cosa molto più complessa.
Sì, sarà disegnato qui in Italia,
ma vedo gli operai cinesi
che l'hanno prodotto,
inquinando l'aria e le acque
delle loro città.
Vedo le guerre nel Medio Oriente
per il petrolio,
materia prima per la plastica,
poi vedo le navi che vanno
dal Medio Oriente in Cina con il petrolio,
e poi quelle che vanno
dalla Cina in Italia con gli occhiali.
E poi, perché è fatto in Cina?
Perché la manodopera costa di meno, sì.
Allora siamo noi che guadagniamo troppo,
o sono loro che guadagnano troppo poco?
E vedete, tutto ciò fa di questo oggetto
una cosa, una meraviglia
che non posso più buttare facilmente via.
Anzi, mi viene da metterlo
su un piedistallo.
Insomma, questo museo, il MAT,
vuole essere una macchina per guardare,
con lo scopo di ritrovare
la meraviglia e il dubbio
per far vedere come tutto
è un po' più complesso
rispetto a quello che ci fa credere
il modello consumistico.
Vuole sistemare questo nostro caos
andando oltre la divisione della modernità
tra natura e società,
tra scienze, arte, fatti, valori.
E facendo così, si spera di scoprire
nuovi modi di vedere e di vivere il mondo.
Modi che possono essere la base
per affrontare i nostri
grandi problemi collettivi.
Voglio finire con un ulteriore pensiero:
è chiaro che un solo museo
rischia di avere poco impatto, no?
Soprattutto se si trova a Laveno Mombello,
qui vicino all'altro lago.
Ma cosa succederebbe,
se ci fosse una rete di tali musei?
Una rete capillare,
un po' come le nostre chiese.
Non è bastato solo San Pietro a Roma,
per diffondere la dottrina della Chiesa.
Ci sono volute chiese,
cappelle e pievi dappertutto.
E non basta solo TED,
per diffondere le idee.
Ci vogliono tutte quelle TEDx.
Allora, oltre al MAT,
stiamo anche pensando già
a una specie di MATx.
E di questo stavo parlando
con il mio amico.
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Di questo stavo parlando
con il mio amico Fabio, qualche mese fa.
E lui diceva: "Beh,
bisogna parlare con Francesco".
E io: "Francesco chi?"
"Papa Francesco!"
"Addirittura Papa Francesco!
Ma vuoi dire usare le chiese come musei?"
Infatti.
Credo che sia bello per tutti
entrare in una chiesa.
Dalla luce riverberante della città
dentro quello spazio buio e silenzioso,
dove la frenesia si ferma.
Ma oltre a poter salutare
il Dio Padre e i suoi Santi, se volete,
o riflettere sulla vita dopo la morte,
perché non potersi fermare
davanti a un'opera,
a una meraviglia che ci fa riflettere
sulla vita di oggi?
Perché non dedicare un altare
alla nostra casa comune,
come lo stesso Papa Francesco chiama
questo indissolubile intreccio
tra natura e uomo?
Grazie.
(Applausi)